Ray a big victory for you with black
pieces plus one right now how do you
feel after this this game
I feel pretty good I mean it was a very
complicated game and I didn't have that
much time so I was a little bit worried
but yeah somehow in the end of the game
things went very well for me it felt
like he surprised you with his opening
Choice tell us about that yeah I mean he
played this three Bishop F4 which is a
funny move I think Magnus played it
against Wesley once Navy and he was kind
of basically the first person to do it
and it was funny I think the European
Club cup uh finished a few days ago and
yeah a few days ago I saw one of the the
games where I played Bishop F4 I think
maybe white even won or got a good
position and I was thinking oh I should
probably just look at this and then I
completely forgot about it of course I
never expected him to play it against me
today so I couldn't yeah I mean I knew
D5 is is trying to take advantage of the
bishopone F4 takes Knight takes Bishop
G3 C5 so this was actually the game
that's probably why I recognized it but
uh yeah after E4 and I did too I had to
make a decision obviously I could take
the pawn but
yeah I was a bit worried I mean he's
just gonna play Knight F3 Bishop D3 E5
and I have this extra Pawn by something
like this yeah
you decided to get a similar position
but without the pawn on D4 how did you
come to that conclusion I I just wanted
to be as safe as possible but I knew I
might be objectively worse here
um I really wasn't sure I think this I
think just slightly yeah yeah I think
this plan of A5 was very nice
um
and I want to basically I just always
keep my Bishop on C5 now he can't kick
it with B4 and I'm always offering the
pawn he can always take it if he wants
but I'll just exchange light squared
Bishops and also bring this c69 it takes
takes yeah
six here um let's take Knight F yeah
Bishop basics for example yeah Bishop A6
I'll exchange these Bishops and put the
other Knight in F5
and I'm down a pawn but my Knights are
great I was supported by this E6 pawn
and I should just be able to put
pressure on the the B Pawn and I felt
I'm not in too much danger in these
types of positions so I thought this was
a good practical uh and the assessment
agrees more or less with you yeah that
seems to be the case definitely
compensation but he probably should have
tried to take the pawn in some version
because I think what he did I must be
completely fine at least
um yep yeah some weird moves rookie one
and then then that H4 couldn't predict
these moves but actually Knight H4 was
was interesting
um it felt like he was trying to find a
way towards your King right yeah I think
also he just wanted to complicate things
as much as possible make me burn time
and then just flag me so
um so I felt like Knight takes G3 was
probably correct here otherwise I was
afraid he would get an attack Bishop B7
here Queen H5 was surprising I thought
he was just gonna play more positionally
just reroute the Knight to D4 probably
and I thought this was playable um B5 or
yeah maybe B5 Knight D4
um if I played B4 he plays A4 so I
thought this would be you know playable
for him Queen H5 was much more
aggressive but somehow I didn't really
see what he was actually going to do
because even if he brings a knight to G5
it takes a few moves and I just play H6
and he goes back so I like the B5 bring
my Rook that was completely offsides yes
into the game and I felt kind of safe on
the position just I was worried about
the time obviously so o'clock yeah I
think he was just going completely all
out putting trying to put uh pressure on
me because he gave this pawn and he went
for F5 very quickly and did you feel he
missed Knight to C3 or was it already
too late at that point I don't think he
missed it I think he probably if he
missed something it might have been
Bishop takes F6 next move which I think
was a good move and I think yeah this
probably just refutes uh this whole plan
yeah I think uh if not for Bishop to F6
you're actually losing so instead of
Knight C3 originally I was uh thought G6
would be safe and then takes let's say h
takes Queen H6
um like if he gets a rook to the H file
just get mated but it's kind of hard for
him to get there so at first I thought
oh I can still play Knight C3 but then I
realized his threat's actually 96 and I
probably just lose yeah yeah so then I
started calculating Knight C3 it looks
very dangerous after F6 but then I
realized Bishop F6 might actually just
be working so I spent some time but it
seemed like everything just just worked
so I had to go for it and here yeah I
mean he could have played EF and FG
um I was probably gonna play with d8 I
don't know if that was the best but yeah
he really didn't have any attack here
and if he plays something like let's
just say Knight C6
Rook takes D1 Knight E7 check first king
takes G7 and let's say queen takes D1 I
mean I have many many things I can do
but one idea that's always nice is I
have this queen A7 checking H2 Rook
takes a G2 check and a lot of lines very
nice yeah yeah so actually a checkmate
yeah so he went for the other the other
way but
um unfortunately he's always tied down
to G2 so he can't bring his Knight into
the attack and so it should just uh not
be enough yeah yeah as long as you don't
blunder like Yasser did between A7 we're
not mentioning any names by the way
we're not mentioning any names of course
King to h8 and after that it was a
smooth sailing for you uh Ray
congratulations uh plus one right now
how do you feel about your chances to
potentially take it all home
oh I mean I think we're still not even
halfway through the tournament so that's
true uh yeah I mean my I had a kind of
difficult pairings at the start I played
most of the top guys so just kind of
got through with a bunch of draws and uh
yeah I mean obviously I'll take my
chances look for some wins but
everyone's super strong I'm just gonna
try to keep doing what I've been doing I
think I'm playing at a pretty good level
so um yeah I'm happy with how I'm doing
so far guys
congratulations Ray just really really
nice uh Victory there hanging and
refuting the attack difficult but well
done Ray your first win and five draws
uh rest day was uh uh was very useful
for you yeah
yeah
I was wondering how it was was it
difficult to play this position was not
so much time on your clock I mean it was
still sharp and you had to check all
these variations how did you do it where
you calm or you were nervous at this
moment oh I definitely wasn't calm I
mean I was uh I think I was on the video
could probably sound like jumping around
a lot but
um no I think at a certain moment in the
game I started to speed up a lot and
when things yeah got extremely direct at
the end
um yeah it wasn't actually a big problem
because I think the calculations were
pretty straightforward and they all seem
to be working out for me so yeah I had
to spend some time on Bishop takes F6
but after that I think the position kind
of played itself pretty much so yeah
after that was pretty calm yeah thank
you I mean really great job seriously
very well done I mean
that's also really Mark of a champion
too keeping your nerves in this moment
when you are